All right, folks, welcome back.
Our continuing series on the 2022 free ICT mentorship
on YouTube.
We're looking at the A-mini S&P June contract
for 2022 daily chart.
All right.
So I'm going to teach you a little bit about intraday
profiles and daily range.
And we're going to be using this idea here.
So initially on Twitter, if you were
following me on that platform, I mentioned
how I was going to start the day looking
for a potential run to 40.70.
So 40.70 was my initial draw on liquidity
to see if it would want to reach down into that level.
If you look in this area here, that's my fair value gap.
You can see we traded down into it here.
Then today, one more time, we traded down into it,
left these relative equal lows in place,
and then started to move higher.
I took everybody's attention to previous day's high
and this high here.
And if this continues to go higher,
I mentioned this before.
I can't recall what video.
But I know I mentioned it in here.
This is where we could potentially
draw up to for an intermediate term target or objective.
But I'm not cosigning that just yet.
Right here and here is enough, OK?
So we're expecting higher prices after this shift
in intraday volatility.
So we'll look at that now going into lower timeframes.
All right, here's the hourly chart.
You can see how we did not take these relative equal lows out.
I wanted to see it go down there.
That's what I was looking for, to try to draw it into that.
It didn't do it.
It did not give a setup either based on the model
I'm teaching you.
So I used the intraday volatility and the framework
to kind of like teach it today a little bit more about bias,
how to change gears with your bias,
how to also manage your bias.
So initially, in the beginning of the morning,
I was looking for a potential run to 40.70.
It gave an opportunity to tape read, quote unquote,
paper trade, or even demo, using the draw liquidity.
But the model itself didn't materialize, OK?
So because I'm the author of these concepts,
I have a lot of tools at my disposal.
And I have a little bit better understanding of price delivery
than the average student of mine.
So if I go in and I show you something in this lecture
today, the main takeaways before I get into it is this.
What did I do, and how do I go about abandoning
a specific bias?
How do I change gears if it is applicable?
Sometimes it's not applicable to reverse.
It just means move to the sidelines
and just say, I'm not going to do anything.
And what are the characteristics that
would lead to a bias that is changed?
And how do you use that logic going forward?
And how to navigate the New York lunch hour?
So we're going to tackle those topics in this video.
So notice that we had this low here taken with this run.
Then this low was taken with this run.
And this low was taken with that run.
So notice what we were seeing.
We're seeing multiple lows get taken.
And then the market reverses while offering really
no high probability shorting opportunity.
The 40-70 level never got tagged.
Liquidity left in place.
Previous day's high, which is here, that high
was not traded to.
So we have a high of 41.68 and a quarter.
And then we have a fair value gap over here.
So you have two premium arrays that
may be a draw on liquidity that takes us up in there.
And it may be even run above these relative equal highs.
All right.
On the 15-minute time frame, you can
see how we just kept going lower than the previous lows.
And then finally, we had a run higher.
So we had a short-term shift in market structure
relative to the 15-minute time frame.
Remember, that's our bellwether chart.
So it runs higher, creates a fair value gap in here,
and trades down into it here.
One of the things I want to bring to your attention,
because a lot of you are familiar with a gentleman
by the name of Chris Laurie.
And he talks about liquidity voids,
where he teaches how the market wants to come back down
and fill all that area in.
As you probably noticed, I don't teach that.
I teach, obviously, there's times when that can occur.
But because I understand the algorithm,
that is not likely to occur most times.
So it's important to know where the market's reaching for.
And then look for these imbalances in price.
And then what makes it a fair value gap
is the fact that it's coming down into this area here
or inside this area here, or this area here,
or this area here.
So they're all fair value gaps.
It's a fair value to buy it if you're bullish, OK?
I'm not trying to insist that these imbalances completely
rebalance.
That's one of the main differentiations
between me and Chris Laurie.
Now, I'm not knocking Chris Laurie,
because I believe if you want to learn price action,
it's basic and goes beyond the average retail stuff,
then you can learn from him.
He's the only one I really give a nod to in technical analysis
and as far as education.
And I send people there all the time.
I don't have a relationship with him on a business level.
He doesn't give me any kickbacks.
I don't ask for anything.
I just think he's a genuinely nice guy, OK?
So there you go.
But there is a stark contrast between what he does
and what I do and how I teach.
So there's a degree of precision that
is given to you when you understand
the things I'm teaching you.
It goes beyond simply imbalance, rebalance.
While that is important, there are times when that is a factor.
But what I'm teaching you is where is the market
likely to go to, OK?
I'm not trying to teach you entry patterns
with an importance that getting in a specific price level
is the most important factor.
I'm teaching you how to determine where the market's
likely to go to next.
Where is that draw on liquidity?
Now, there's a lot of different ways
that that is calculated on an institutional level, OK,
and how it's determined.
It's not buying and selling pressure, OK?
But it is algorithmic.
So the easiest way for me to cut through all
of the very complicated things that could very
easily bog you down.
And you may feel like the things I'm teaching are complicated.
And I guess when you remove the idea of putting an indicator
that says you're overbought or oversold,
or a crossing over of two lines that gives you a buy or sell,
it's not, in my opinion, wisdom to exchange a decision,
especially if you ever decide to do this with real money.
It's not wise for you to determine
your bet, or your gamble, or your investment
on what an indicator is saying versus reading price action
and getting the logic behind what it's doing, OK?
And that's narrative.
What is narrative?
Narrative is the understanding of what price should do, why,
and what things will it encounter
to prove that the narrative that you are assuming is in place
is, in fact, underway.
Now, that's a mouthful, I'm sure.
Most of you probably didn't get much out of that,
but I'm going to break it down for you.
I was looking for $40.70 today to see
if it can get down outside the range of that daily fair value
gap.
And we failed to do so.
And then the market shifted higher.
Now, the whole time I'm looking at the market,
it's not giving me any kind of short.
I'm not comfortable taking any kind of short.
And all of a sudden, the market does this.
OK, no panic.
No, I'm missing a move.
No calling somebody else or reaching out
to somebody on a social media platform
and ask them, what do you think is happening?
I don't worry about anybody else's opinion.
You shouldn't worry about anybody else's opinion either.
You're going to learn how to trust yourself.
So we had created a fair value gap here
on the 15-minute time frame.
So right away, that is your area to watch and see
if price supports a run.
If it digs into that and starts to repel higher,
and we take out this short-term high,
that is enough to set up a stage for the afternoon trend.
That afternoon session move or setup or price swing,
that's what we're looking for now.
Because the market failed to go to an objective
we were looking for, it was respecting that daily fair value
gap.
And it rallied up.
And what fair value gap is that?
At the beginning of the video, I showed you on the daily chart.
Here, it took out that short-term high.
So now we have an absolute market structure shift,
bullish with this swing high.
And the market comes back down in here
and rebalances this fair value gap.
Now, I'm not looking at, and this
is one of the instances where resistance broken,
turns support, but it digs a little bit past that.
Notice that it goes down into my fair value gap,
not stopping dead in its tracks right at the high.
Notice that?
So I'm not looking at support and resistance.
I'm looking at the fact that we went
through this short-term high, created an imbalance,
and then we traded that into that.
And then when we get into this area here,
I'm interested in looking at intermarket relationships.
I want to study real accumulation and distribution.
How do I do that?
I've already told you.
We're going to go into a lower time frame, five-minute chart.
So here's the five-minute chart.
As you can see, the market did drop down.
It did a real quick sudden move after I tweeted,
saying that my initial interest was $40.70.
And it started drawing lower.
And then went one more time here at 10 after 9,
took out that short-term low there,
and then it started rallying higher at 9.30's opening.
And then we dig down into that 15-minute time frame
fair value gap.
So it doesn't look like a fair value gap in here.
Notice that?
But I want you to go back to your 15-minute chart.
This is where the work is required on your part.
In this price run from here to here on that 15-minute chart,
look at your chart and shade that in on the 15-minute time frame,
and then drop down into the five-minute,
and you'll see how it drops into that shaded area.
So we're working from a higher time frame,
15-minute bellwether chart into a five-minute chart.
This is running into that fair value gap.
Now, if you're just staying on one time frame,
or at least not carrying over higher time frame analysis
into your lower time frame, you're going to be trading blind.
You have no idea what you're looking for.
Now, I know what I'm looking for,
because I have multiple charts in front of me,
multiple monitors, and I'm panning around.
When I do my recordings, like I did this morning,
you can see that I actually executed the trade.
You can see where I got in.
You can see the actual executions.
You can see the little arrows that show where I got in.
I show the price, and you can see the partials along the way
and the whole business, okay?
So if you're not following me on Twitter,
you don't need to follow me.
I'm not asking you to follow me, but you can go to Twitter,
and you can see that that is, in fact, shown to you.
Short little vignettes, I call them stingers, okay?
I do small little segments of me actually trading
or I'll do analysis or commentary
without really saying anything,
and I'll play music behind it, because I'm having fun.
I'm enjoying myself.
Hopefully, you guys over here on Twitter are having fun with me.
If you're digging it and you're enjoying yourself
on my Twitter feed, give me a heads up in the comments below.
All right, so anyway, it digs down into that 15-minute time frame,
fair value gap here, and then rallies higher.
Then it starts to trail off and goes down
into this imbalance right here.
Now, in that little stinger video,
I draw this little area out with a rectangle,
and I do a small little box up here, okay?
And what that box is, is if it goes down into here
and starts to rally, I'm going to take half that position off
once it gets into this area here again, okay?
I don't need to go above this short-term high,
so that's what that little red rectangle represents
when you see me doing that stinger little vignette video
on my Twitter feed.
I'm drawing your attention here, so when we go from this level here,
if it starts to rally up, once it gets back up in that area again,
I'm going to take half the position off
and then see if it can run about that high.
Okay, so that's what I was drawing to.
I'm drawing reference to that so that way when I talk to you tonight,
because this is our Tuesday lecture,
I'm showing you now what it is that I was referring to
and why it was there.
Also, if you scrub back over here,
you'll see it's an old area of bicep liquidity here,
and it's a fair value gap over there too, okay?
So that little rectangle here is drawing special attention to me
reminding myself that over here, there's bicep liquidity
that is not showing in that video that I'm recording
and in that imbalance over here.
So when it runs back up into that, this old area of bicep liquidity,
this might be just a stop run,
and then they're going one more time passing into that level.
So I want to make sure I get half my position off
because I could be wrong, like I was wrong about 40.70,
didn't trade to it.
Well, here at 10.35, right there, 10.35, right there,
I tweeted, I said, note your previous day's high, okay?
Previous day's high is here.
So if we add the annotations back to the chart,
and we'll remember that 41.68, what price is that?
41.68 and a quarter.
So that's our high that we're likely to draw to.
That's what I was kind of drawing everyone's attention to.
And I'll now add the annotations back.
All right, so here is what I had in the recording.
I shaded this area in here.
It was like a shaded box.
I just drew these really prominent lines here
so that we can recall that to the pair of headgap
that I showed in that little vignette video.
And I want to talk a little bit about New York lunch, okay?
I gave you rules of engagement
when you're trading the afternoon session.
And primarily, what I gave you for the model
was a morning session idea.
But because of all the people asking and inquiring,
hey, can you teach us a little bit about the PM session
or the afternoon setup,
I started bringing in some things.
Now, if the market starts to go higher, okay?
In other words, if we've been in a bullish market structure
and order flow is bullish,
that means everything's going in one direction,
the market's obviously going higher on all timeframes,
then that's an easy trading scenario.
But we're inside that little trading range area
on the daily chart last few days or a week or so.
It's just been hanging around that smaller range.
So you have to know what you're doing
or you're going to get caught up.
So initially, I wanted that 40-70 level.
We failed to go outside this shaded area here.
That's that daily fair value gap.
So I've added it here for your notification.
Notice that these lows here, here,
this is lower than that one.
Why is that important?
Why am I drawing a distinction between those two?
Well, if you go and you add your NASDAQ chart overlay,
you'll see that this is a divergence.
So even the S&P was relatively stronger
than that of the NASDAQ.
NASDAQ made a lower low here, okay?
And I'll show you that before I close the lecture out.
But for now, this is that five-minute chart
returning back into that 15-minute imbalance.
So that's there for your edification as well.
This is the opening price at midnight.
That's what that level is.
Now, I teach if we're bullish,
we wanna be buying at or close to the opening price, okay?
Now, here's one of those advanced ICT things, okay?
If you know that the market is likely to go down to go up,
then you can wait for price to give you
this type of setup right here,
where it goes down, shift in market structure,
come back down into a 15-minute timeframe fair value gap.
This is intraday or day trading.
It is not the model I gave you where it is a scalp.
Essentially, that's what that is.
The model I've provided for you for this YouTube channel
is a scalping model.
That's exactly what it is.
But if you're gonna day trade daily range,
you're gonna be using the 15 and five-minute chart.
And there it is.
Now, you can use that model that I gave you
for entries and scalping.
You can use that as your entry criteria,
but with the logic and narrative
that you're gonna be trading the daily range, okay?
So, if we're bullish, I teach and I have taught
on this YouTube channel multiple times.
My power three concept is if we're bullish,
we're gonna be looking for the opening price at midnight.
It's gonna drop down, create the low of the day.
It's forming at 9.10, New York local time.
It rallies up, shift in market structure.
So, it doesn't give me my objective,
but it gives me these clues here.
Now, the whole time, I'm not tweeting to you.
I'm studying price.
I'm working with my son and I'm measuring all these things
because last word I gave on Twitter was
I was looking for 40.70.
No problem, no trade either.
But I mentioned that there was no setup,
there's nothing going on, and then the market rallies up.
Okay, what I was looking for, it didn't reach it,
and it didn't give me a setup.
Did I lose any money?
Did I take any kind of a painful ego twist to my arm?
No.
Was I wrong in the public eye?
Well, some of you may think that
because it didn't go to 40.70,
but if I'm looking for something to deliver
and it doesn't give me a setup,
last time I checked, if you don't put a trade on,
did you lose?
No.
If you put some skin in the race
and you tell the public what you think's gonna happen
and it doesn't happen, do you lose?
Well, it depends on what your audience's mentality is.
If they're looking for face value,
yeah, I was wrong about 40.70.
You hear that?
ICT didn't get something he thought.
40.70 didn't print.
No problem.
I don't need to be right.
The SMT divergence here in the higher low
versus the lower low in NASDAQ comparably,
and then we have that shift in market structure,
we trade back down into the 15-minute fair value gap here,
and then we rally once more.
Once I saw that, then I'm good to go,
I'm waiting for the afternoon setup.
But now watch what's happening.
The market rallies up, falls short of 41.40.
That was another level I gave
in that little Stinger video on my Twitter feed.
So I'm gonna count you over and check that out.
And then it drops down into the fair value gap,
starts to rally, but look what it does.
It leaves these smooth relative equal highs
and then does what?
Drops once more below that short-term low.
Now think about what I've given you in your notes
as it relates to trading the PM or afternoon session.
If you're bullish, generally what'll happen
is the market has ran higher in the morning,
then it consolidates into the lunch hour,
then after the lunch hour,
it'll drop down and sweep the sell stops
or below some short-term low or the lows made in lunch.
Okay, now watch what this does here.
It creates a low ahead of the lunch hour at noon.
Then it drops down into the fair value gap.
Is that not doing what I gave you in terms of the rules
of what liquidity is doing in the afternoon
post New York lunch when we're bullish?
Yes.
What's different?
It's not consolidating.
See that?
Is this a consolidation?
No, it's a retracement.
So if you can identify an area where it's likely to retrace
and some of you asked on the Twitter feed,
why am I measuring from here to here
to get this versus this here to here?
Well, you have to ring in what I'm trying to do.
I'm trading the daily range.
I'm trying to get the majority
or the lion's portion of the daily range.
So because I'm doing that,
I'm factoring in that midnight opening price.
So we've went above it here and once more.
So I'm not expecting it to go back down below here again.
So to refer to this low now again is pointless.
I'm gonna use this one here for market structure.
So market structure swing low here to swing high.
That's my dealing range.
So that's why I aligned that one here.
Okay.
And I gave you that small little rectangle up here
drawing my attention in the video here
to go back to what I mentioned moments ago
that that's an old imbalance and it may stall here.
It may fail here.
It may just consolidate and then run
for previous days high, you know, on Wednesday.
So I wanna take half my trade off,
which is basically what you saw me do.
But anyway, it's taking out that short-term low
on a retracement.
But if it was consolidating into lunch,
I would look for the swing lows during the lunch hour
and then wait for the drop down,
sweep them like it's doing here and then rally.
But because this is a retracement going into lunch,
that to me, it signals that they're gonna work
through lunch.
What does that mean?
Years ago, when we were on the floor only open outcry,
sometimes the floor traders would know
that the market was in a hurry.
It's a fast market.
So they're not going off the floor.
They're gonna stay busy on the floor
and they're gonna be trading.
So I learned this from the actual floor trader.
So I'm not making it up.
I'm not, you know, just giving you some kind
of garbage meetup or some contrived nonsense.
It's based on what they used to do.
And that same mentality has been transferred
into electronic trading.
So the algorithm does that same thing here.
During the lunch hour, if it's a fast market,
it's retracing back down in to a random fare that you got.
It creates a short-term low
and then it runs the only short-term low that's there
from here to here.
This is too narrow.
We don't want that.
It's already moved too much.
And it's going into that hour ahead of lunchtime,
noon to one, New York local time.
So I wanna see it retrace back down into a discount.
How has that done from that low to high?
So the algorithm reprices to a discount
once it gets to here, then it does what?
Creates that short-term low,
rallies a little bit, leaves smooth highs in here.
So what is that?
They think that is resistance.
So anyone that's short, they trade their stock loss here
and then drops one more time right below that short-term low.
What's below that short-term low?
I have already told you here.
Sell stops.
So I'm thinking, like smart money,
this is gonna go higher in the afternoon.
I didn't take anything in here in the morning.
And I was not correct in where I thought it could reach for,
which is 40.70.
If it would have went to 40.70,
you know what I would have done?
Said, there's your 40.70.
And you would have asked, did you take a trade?
Or the cynics would have said,
but you didn't take a trade.
That's not what I'm trying to teach you.
I'm not trying to teach you entries.
I'm teaching you the logic on how to read the markets
that way.
Once you get this skill set down,
the entries are the easiest thing to do.
They're the, that's the easiest thing to do.
But you have to know how to read the market
and also tell when the market's turning.
And what is, if it's turning, where's it gonna go?
And if it's gonna go higher, where will setups form?
I showed you that today, right on Twitter,
right there in front of everybody.
Now, the market drops down into the sell stops here
and it's inside that fair value gap.
And it's happening in the lunch hour.
Now I had things I had to take care of
and I was gonna be away from the screens as I was.
And I didn't think I'd be back before two o'clock,
but I was managing that trade from my cell phone.
And you can see that cell phone trade management
in the short little vignette.
You can see the stops being raised
and I'm taking partials along the way, the whole business.
But as it's going up into this area here,
I'm taking some of the contracts off
and I'm raising the stop loss up
because I don't want it to come back down
into that fair value gap again,
because what it done is once, twice,
it should never come back down that again.
If it does, I'm wrong.
And I don't wanna be a part of that trade.
If I'm in a position that's still open
or have a partial open from the original position
after partials have been taken,
then I'm gonna kill the trade
and I'll move to the sidelines.
But the main thing I want you to understand about this is
I'm not trading the model that I'm teaching on YouTube.
And you're probably gonna say,
well, why don't you just trade the model, Michael?
Why don't you just teach us how to use the model?
I am.
When the model speaks, I'm gonna show you.
But I'm also teaching you how you still learn to read price
when the model isn't giving you a setup
because every single market isn't gonna give you
that model's entry setup and framework every single day,
every single session.
And because I'm the author of these concepts,
I don't have a limitation to just that one.
So is it beneficial for you to have me say nothing
when the model says nothing,
or is it beneficial for me to teach you
how to read price action,
how to get in sync and learn how to change gears
when the market shows you it's time to change gears?
I think that's a little bit better expectation
on the part of a student with that of a mentor
that has the experience I'm trying to share with you.
So there's two camps that's gonna be looking at this video
and they're gonna say, he's not really a good teacher
because he's not focusing on the model.
When I'm telling you the model didn't do anything today
in this index.
So what did I lean on?
My experience, my ability and the concepts
that are already taught in this YouTube channel.
So one of the Twitter followers I mentioned today
that can they use timeframes outside of the one
through five minute chart, but use the same logic.
Yes, yes, that's all I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to teach you a mindset
that on the lowest timeframe,
it gives you a lot of experience, a lot of setups,
a lot of things to practice,
but don't limit yourself to that
because there's so many other ways to trade
using what I'm teaching you
and you can scale it to whatever timeframe
and whatever chart you wanna use it on.
But you still have to understand what price is likely to do
and where is it drawing to.
So let's talk a little bit about narrative.
When the market shifted here bullishly
and it came back down into that 50 minute timeframe
fair value gap and then rallied,
this right here told me that they wanna set this up
for a bullish run in the afternoon.
Why?
Go back to that daily chart.
Remember we were inside this shaded area here.
That's the fair value gap that I did not shade
when we were looking at the daily chart naked
at the beginning of the video.
If you shade that on your own chart,
you'll see when you drop down the lower timeframe
five minute chart, yours will look like this.
So it dips down into that lower end of that
fair value gap and then rallies,
trades back down into the 15 minute timeframe
fair value gap, which is what that is here.
Then it rallies.
Now, right away in my mind,
this tells me that the algorithm is priming itself
for an afternoon run to potentially previous days high,
which is this level up here.
So from here, right when it crossed over here,
I'm thinking, okay,
it could potentially be running previous days high.
I don't know it yet.
Then when it drops down into here
and then rallies from that, then I know it.
Now that's narrative.
By itself, it doesn't mean go in there and buy it
because hey, the narrative says it's gonna probably run
to previous days high because I could see myself stopped out
if I'm premature.
I wanna see something that makes sense logically.
So that means, do we see displacement?
Yeah, we do.
Is that an energetic price run?
Oh yeah, it is.
Then that low to that high,
I wanna get that measurement for premium to discount.
And what do I wanna wait for?
A discount.
So I measured from that low to that high
in that short little vignette video on my Twitter feed
and 50% and went below that and that's the fair value gap.
So it trades down into here, creates a short term low
and then drops into here.
Now what happens if it went here and rallied?
Okay, well, I would have missed a move.
But I'm looking for sell-side liquidity.
I wanna see a stop run because what that's doing
and how this fits into the narrative is if I'm thinking
that this move here to here and then retracing down
and setting up an afternoon run
to potentially this level here by the close of the day,
I wanna be like smart money and do what?
Buy sell-stops.
I'm buying sell-side liquidity.
My order, as it's underneath here, I fill right here.
I'm buying it on this candle right there.
I know you probably don't believe me.
I'm gonna show you the candlesticks in a minute.
But I drop down into it, I go long there
and then I wait for it to rally up.
So it starts to rally up,
it consolidates a little bit in here
and then starts to almost come out above this high
and it creates a little small consolidation
and then pumps it through the old high and the 41.40 level.
Creates a short-term high, rallies once more.
I draw a line on here
because I wanna see if price can be supported
by that down close candle.
That's eight order block.
It trades through it and once it did that,
I nixed the trade, okay?
I have taken a lot of the trade off through here
and I'm also in an environment still inside
that daily range of multiple days on the daily chart
where it might not go to previous days high today.
So this might be it
and it might need to use Wednesday's trading.
So that was my thought process
for closing the trading and protecting my stop loss,
which never would have been hit
because the stop was below here.
But it came down, closed in this fair,
then it got a ride again.
This was an optimal trade entry once more,
pushing it higher,
but still did not hit the previous day's high.
Now think about this, folks.
Think, at the beginning of the day,
I tweeted public knowledge.
I wanna see initially
if it wants to make a run down the 40.70, okay?
And as soon as I tweeted it,
it was like off the race as it goes.
Right in here, boom.
And then boom.
And then drifted down to it here
and it made a low of 40.76 even.
Didn't break out below the fair day gap
that's formed on the daily chart.
That's again, that shaded area here.
And I'd have this tweet here
so you can see that's the time of 10.35.
That's when I said, nope, yesterday's high.
So that is there on this candle.
And here, 10.35, I'm tweeting,
note, previous day's high.
So I'm drawing your attention up here.
So if a retracement comes back down
into what I shared in that video beforehand,
before it even came down here,
I'm showing you this.
And I gave you this level up here
as previous day's high in chart format
in the video showing you that this is where my mindset is.
Think up here.
This is where it's gonna draw to likely.
And it's gonna retrace down to this level here.
So right away, this should tell you
for the folks that are paying attention,
ICT says that it's probably gonna go up in the afternoon
and it's probably gonna gravitate towards this level up here
which is previous day's high.
And he's showing this level here
where he's taught optimal trade entry, fair value gap.
When it goes down to here, it's in what, a discount.
So we're moving from a discount to buy-sell liquidity.
So the premium array is up here, the discount array is here.
Doesn't it make sense for you to anticipate the move
or originating basically from here,
running above here, taking a partial
and seeing if it can gravitate towards the high?
Yes.
So you studied that way.
So that's what I do with my students in my private group.
That's what I'm doing with you, okay?
Folks, listen, I've had thousands of emails
come to me in the last couple months
asking to let you all in my private group.
My private group is done.
I don't even make videos for them anymore, okay?
We just chit chat on a form now.
That's all it is.
I'm teaching mentorship right here for free.
You don't have to have a PayPal account.
You don't have to give me a credit card number.
You don't have to worry about missing your payment, nothing.
All you have to do is show up every time I do this
or show up over there on Twitter,
see what I'm doing over there.
And I promise you, if you stick with it,
the things I'm teaching you work.
I absolutely use this logic today.
I didn't create something new today.
This is exactly what I'm teaching you.
As a mentorship, this is it.
I did the very thing I'm teaching you with
so that way you can see a button was pushed.
Do I need to put a trade on every single day to teach you?
No.
Will I continue to show trades?
Yes.
Will you be accepted into my private group?
No.
So please don't ask, okay?
That community is closed to them
and you are all benefiting and believe me,
they're learning along with you with this mentorship.
Paid members that went through my private group,
they're learning things just like you are right here
because I'm taking things and simplifying them.
If I let you all into that group and took all of your money,
you would all be confused, okay?
Because there's so many things.
It's very, very detailed.
I have simplified it here.
That's all I'm done.
I've made it very simple so that we can go in,
look at these things and make it applicable
because you need to learn how to do this
before it gets hard.
And it's gonna get real hard, folks.
Read between the lines and think about what I'm saying.
Look around, the world's changing, okay?
So put in the time, don't rush it.
You don't need to worry about taking a year
to learn how to do this.
I've streamlined this, okay?
I'm here until the good Lord takes me
or takes away my mental faculties.
I'm on YouTube, okay?
I'm on Twitter.
I love doing this.
I love being back in this capacity.
I'm free to do what I wanna do.
I'm enjoying myself.
And all of you, both private membership
and public mentorship, you're all benefiting from it.
And I'm having fun with you.
So don't mess it all up by stressing me out,
asking me to join a group
that I'm not gonna let you join anyway.
And I don't want your money, so stop asking me.
So anyway, this is where we're at right now.
I think we'll probably wanna sweep up here.
Maybe that might even happen tonight
during the agent session.
But let's take a look at the executions.
And on this candle here, the low on this candle,
look at this figure right here, okay?
That low is 41.11, even.
And the low on this candle comes in at 41.08 1 1⁄4
and my fill, 41.10 1⁄4 below that low.
Whoops, I'm sorry.
I'm doing the wrong one.
The low is 41.10 1⁄2 and then my candle entry was here.
The low was 41.08 1⁄4 and my fill was still below that.
It's 41.10 1⁄4, so 1⁄4 point below that, okay?
So there's the entry right there.
And then partial here and another partial there.
So half the position, about 10 contracts on this price
and took off half in that area
where that rectangle was drawn
in that little vignette video, okay?
Again, I'm doing this, folks, back over here.
See this area here and these are all to equal highs.
I'm thinking that it could do this
and maybe this might be a failure swing, right?
And then go lower.
So I'm taking off half in the event that I'm possibly wrong.
So that's why I did that.
You understand that?
And I took another partial off here.
I tweeted, you know, pay the trader.
Okay, so three contracts there at 41.34 1⁄2
and then I waited for it to pump up through this old high
and the 41.40 level at 41.41 1⁄2.
I was actually, I was like three seconds late.
I was waiting for it to give me a nice big candle.
And if you watch the vignette video,
I sell the one contract
and then it gives that little bit
of a ramped up expansion on the candles.
I'm like, ah, I just would have waited one more,
you know, one more moment.
It could have gave me a better fill, but whatever.
And then here is me closing the remaining one contract
because I was concerned it was gonna take the stop
and then I didn't want it to stop out.
I'd rather take my price at my own exit
and not let the stop out occur.
But it never would have hit here and just rebounds that.
And then at the old high it ran again,
but still failed to get to my objective on the day.
But this was the draw on liquidity.
Now think about what I've shown here.
I was wrong on this level
and I was wrong on the 40.70 level,
but I was able to trade and take the lion's portion
of the move in the middle.
That's all you need.
You don't need to be in here
doing the absolute highest high and the lowest low.
You don't need to do that.
Okay, the folks are asking me,
can you teach me to do that?
You don't need to, look at this.
Wouldn't this keep you from going hungry?
I mean, I think it would.
I mean, this is good eating here.
I mean, this is a nice move.
It makes sense.
And I don't need this level to get profitable.
Old high, yes, yes, and yes.
Okay, so I mentioned I'll go into the SMT,
the version's in here, so let's do that now.
All right, so I'm adding the little compare tab.
It's a little plus symbol up here.
If you go into your trading view,
click on it, it'll give you the dropdown menu
for what instrument or market you wanna compare it to.
And you use NQM2022.
This is gonna change to NQU2022.
And this symbol for S&P will eventually,
in a few days, change to ESU2022.
ESU2022, and it will be basically tracking
the September delivery contract of both indices.
Right now, we're in the month of June,
and it's about to roll over.
So what we do is we monitor chart,
I'm sorry, bar chart.com,
and whenever the open interest is larger
in the September contract than that of the June contract,
that's when I roll over.
So that's how I do it.
It's a little different from everybody else, I'm sure,
but that's what it is I'm doing
when I'm rolling over into the next month,
because these months, or these contracts, they expire.
Okay, so June won't be traded anymore in a couple days,
and September will.
And we'll trade September until a week or so into September,
and then we'll roll over to the December contract,
because September will expire.
All right, so anyway, with the compare tab,
you're putting in this symbol here
as a selection in the dropdown menu,
and once it's down here, you click on a little gear,
and make sure it's highlighted to low,
because what we're doing is we're comparing
and contrasting the lows inside of a fair value gap
after a retracement into a discount
when we're expecting it to potentially trade up in here.
I'm speaking like you knew this, okay?
That's how you're supposed to talk to yourself
in your journal.
This low versus this low.
You see that, low or low?
Is that seen here?
Low, high or low?
We're comparing lows.
So when we're bullish,
we're plotting this line down here
as a compare and contrast tool,
and it's SMT, Smart Money Tool, or Smart Money Technique.
I never really settled on what the T was gonna be,
so that's why I always say it like that,
but it's my way of measuring real accumulation distribution.
So if we know that this area down here is a discount,
and we know this is an imbalance,
fair value gap, it trades down into a pool of liquidity
below that low is sell stops,
and I wanna buy sell stops, like I've mentioned here.
I'm buying the sell stops inside the fair value gap
during a classic buy day,
which is open at midnight, trade down,
create the low of the day, rally,
and then creates an optimal trade entry or fair value gap,
or you're gonna buy the short-term low
during SMT diversions.
Okay, so there's real accumulation here
between the NASDAQ and the S&P.
So this tells me that the NASDAQ is failing to go lower,
so it's under accumulation,
and this is just a stop hunt below that short-term low.
See that?
Now, some of you are like,
this is a really complicated ICT.
I really like the optimal trade entry,
and these fair value gaps are all over the place.
How do I know which one is the one I wanna use?
Okay, check this out.
A lot of you know how to use optimal trade entry.
You'll use the low here to the high, pull your fib up,
62 to 70% traceable level.
If it goes down to that, then you'll buy it.
Okay, that's one pattern,
but now watch what else there is.
This is turtle soup.
You have a low, lower low by the low
that's being violated with optimal trade entry.
See that?
Or you can just do this.
Low, high, find the fair value gap below 50% level,
which is a discount.
Soon it trades to the top level of it,
hit it there, buy it there, stop below the lower low,
or level here.
There's your pattern.
See that?
Or you can do this.
You can wait for it to trade down into this like that,
and then find the swing high prior to it trading
into the fair value gap,
and put a buy stop there as your entry.
And whatever the lowest low is, after it hits that,
that's where your stop loss would be,
just right below that.
And you can be buying strength.
That's not, in my opinion, the preferred entry strategy,
but I just gave you a bunch of them.
But it's using what?
Bias that has been corrected and calibrated
based on what the market has done here at key times.
Okay, so at 930, the market does what?
It brings us that volatility we look for.
So it shifts higher after we have another SMT divergence
here, but we have that shift higher.
It's showing us real accumulation in the SMP.
It rallies.
I don't wanna chase that.
I wait for it to come back down into a 15-minute timeframe,
fair value gap, which it does.
Now, am I still buying it there?
I could, I absolutely could do that,
but I'm not willing to,
because I wanna know that what I thought initially,
which was 40.70, it could still wipe out that low.
It's early on in the day.
So I wanna wait for the market to really communicate to me
that the algorithm is pricing in a narrative
that the afternoon session is bullish,
that's it.
I'm gonna give up the morning session, folks.
See, just because I'm sitting in front of the charts
doesn't mean I'm taking a trade,
because guess what?
I'm gonna take a trade because I've been here all day
and I deserve one.
It doesn't work like that.
You have to wait and be patient.
There's more time waiting in between the setups
than actually doing anything.
And then it's funny.
You have to have incredible patience in both stages.
You have to be very patient waiting for the setup.
And then once you get in a trade,
you have to be patient and let the trade pan out.
Once it comes in the 15-minute timeframe here,
then it rallies like this,
then I'm comfortable knowing what I'm looking for.
What is that?
Dealing range low, dealing range high,
fib across 50% below that, here's the fair value gap,
trade down into it, I wanna buy sell stops.
That's just me.
I wanna do it,
because it really fortifies the setup.
It allows me to get in where the smart money will be buying.
That little movement here, I'm buying that very candle.
I didn't buy the next candle.
I didn't buy the candle before that.
I bought below that price, 41.10 and a half.
I bought it at 41.10 and a quarter.
The things I'm teaching you, I'm pushing a button.
It's a really real instance of happening, not something.
I took a trade and you never see that happening.
I'm showing you example after example after example
of the things I'm teaching you and I'm using the logic.
I'm not creating some falsehood.
I'm not scamming you, I'm not frauding you.
I'm not doing anything except for teaching you what works,
what makes these markets book.
And they do it every single week.
The same kind of stuff all the time.
The SMT divergence here, you see that?
The SMT divergence here, lower low, higher low.
Here we have the lower low in NASDAQ, higher low in SMP.
That sets the stage for that run higher.
Okay.
I could literally go on and on for about four more hours
just in this chart, but I promised myself
I wouldn't make these videos very long.
And I know some of you really want those long ones back,
but I look at the statistics on my videos
and the attention spans about 10 minutes each video.
So I'm gonna try my best to stay in that the SMT.
Can't promise, but I'm certainly gonna do it
as much as I can.
And I'm certainly obviously well beyond that limitation here
but I know a lot of you press that two times
the speed function on the videos and I get it.
If you ever listened to me in a forced live session,
I sound like a different guy, don't I?
That's because I don't have that sped up chipmunk sound.
That you guys usually put me on, but that's cool.
I understand everybody's time is important,
but hopefully you found something in this insightful.
Hopefully you're encouraged by me actually showing it working
and not just talking about something theoretically.
And again, be safe and I'll touch base with you again
on Twitter tomorrow, I'm sure.
And again on Thursday in another lecture in the mentorship.